okay so episode 2 of Chainsaw man is
here and in this video we're about to
break down everything you need to know
during this second episode denji
officially becomes a government double
Hunter and today we'll be explaining who
his new teammates are why one of them
tried to set him up and the huge
differences between the anime and manga
before we get into it though I do these
reviews every week so I'd really
appreciate it if you hit that sub button
if you haven't already and as usual drop
a like if you like the video
alright so at the end of the previous
episode makima gave denji a choice which
is that she either kills him for being a
devil or she keeps him as her pet human
ultimately he chose to survive by
picking option number two and in the
opening scene of this new episode a
topless Genji rides in the car next to
her early on in their conversation
makima kind of sets the tone for their
relationship as she tells him that now
that he's in her care she expects that
whenever she asks him to do something he
should either give a yes answer or just
bought like a dog it was implied that
under no circumstances is he allowed to
tell her no and to me this was a very
important scene for three reasons
firstly it shows that makima literally
views denji as a dog just like the
Yakuza did and in fact if you look
closely during the opening song we can
even see her walking him like a dog on
the beach this demonstrates that even if
denji is free from his dead he still
managed to find himself in a situation
where people are using him like a tool
the other reasons why this moment
matters is that it very quickly
establishes that makima has a dark side
and it shows us how easily denji can be
manipulated what I mean by that is that
after she calls him a dog he gets
offended and starts to realize that she
might be a dangerous person but then as
soon as she does something nice he
immediately forgets about it and chooses
to only focus on her good side in this
episode alone it happened two separate
times and I think this is a case of
denji's subconsciously choosing to
ignore the red flags because at the end
of the day makama is enabling him to
live his dream life anyhow as they ride
in the car denji's stomach loudly starts
to growl and this is because the last
thing he ate was just a plain slice of
bread the previous day hearing this
noise makima offers to take him to
breakfast and pay for anything he wants
and on top of that she gives him her
jacket so he can cover himself from
denji's point of view this was
mind-blowing on a few different levels
since it's the first time another human
has been this nice to him usually most
people don't even go near him because he
smells so bad so the fact a girl is
willing to hug him buy him food and give
him a jacket he falls in love with her
straight away regardless of how
dangerous she might be as they arrive at
the cafe this is when the biggest
difference between the anime and manga
takes place as the anime cuts out an
entire scene with when denji fought
against the devil for the purpose of
this video I'm going to summarize what
happens in that fight and why I think it
was taken out and I'd recommend that you
watch this part even if you only care
about the episode okay so in the Maga
denji orders his food and then
immediately after that a random man
comes up to them asking for help he
tells makima that a devil kidnapped his
daughter and took her into the forest
and usually something like that would be
the job of the public safety devil
Hunters however In This Moment makima
doesn't want to get involved since her
noodles will get soggy if she's gone for
too long and instead she sends denji to
deal with it when denji then questions
this decision she reminds him that he
has to do anything she says and
basically she threatens to kill him if
he doesn't prove that he's useful in the
anime these words were repurposed so
that she says it to him in the car
instead but in any case after being
threatened a frightened denji then runs
into the words where he finds the
missing girl playing with her cute
looking devil the girl begs him to let
the devil go as she claims that it saved
her from her abusive Father which
reminds the NG of how pachita saved him
when he was younger not wanting to kill
the cute devil he proposes that the
three of them run away together and
start a new life because he knows that
makama will murder him if he comes back
empty-handed the young girl then happily
agrees this plan to run away but as she
makes contact with denji her pet devil
suddenly transforms into this gigantic
creature as it turns out this monster is
the muscle devil and as the name
suggests is able to control the muscles
of any person is touching this means
that the whole time it was controlling
the girl to make her say what it wanted
her to say and by luring denge Yin his
muscles are now under its control
however in response denji manages to
pull the cord on his chest by using his
mouth instead of his hands and after
turning into chainsaw man he rips apart
the muscle devil and brings the guards
safely back to her dad when he sees
makama again he then accidentally
collapses into her chest due to him
losing a ton of blood during his fight
with the muscle devil ultimately the
reason I think this was cut was due to
pacing since episode 1 adapted 55 pages
of the manga whereas episode 2 is in
theory meant to adapt over 70 pages to
do this in a way that feels natural I
guess they decided that the muscle devil
was something they didn't 100 need to
put in given that this villain isn't
important and the episode still flows
well without it being there now at the
cafe makama and denji talk about how he
originally turned into chainsaw man in
the first place and in the process we
learned that pachita isn't dead but
rather he's physically alive inside of
denji's body thanks to machama's special
know she has the ability to smell that
this is the case and following that she
feeds him his noodles after he pretends
that he can't beat himself based on her
facial expressions you can tell that
she's generally intrigued by him because
in all likelihood she's never met
someone who can shift between being a
devil and a human a will makami even
mentions in this scene how the condition
is so rare that it doesn't even have a
name and this Rarity is why he's so
valuable to her even if he might be an
idiot moving on because denji has a
crush on her he anxiously asks makima if
there's a type of guy she likes and this
is interesting because in the first
episode one of his main Ambitions was to
flirt with a girl him now asking her
this question is probably the most
direct unsubtle way of flirting
imaginable showing us that you know
although it might have been his dream
he's still not quite sure how to do it
properly despite that makima does
respond with the same energy as she says
that she's into the dingy type but
because he's so bad at this it takes him
a while to realize who she's talking
about by the way in case you're
wondering what her true feelings are
keep in mind that she's only known denji
for a few hours the only reason she
didn't kill him is because he's obeying
her like a dog and by his own admission
he smells terrible I guess that should
give you a rough idea of what she thinks
about him but regardless the episode
then moves over to Tokyo devil Hunter HQ
this building is the main base for all
public safety devil hunters in the city
and before we continue it's worth
explaining how the system works in Japan
you have two types of devil Hunters
which are the public safety devil
Hunters like makima and the civilian
devil Hunters like the guy we see later
in the episode civilian devil Hunters
are essentially self-employed meaning
they get to decide how often they want
to work and which Devils they want to go
after they then get paid bounties from
the government depending on which type
of devil they kill and if authorized
they can make contracts with Devils to
boost their own power in comparison
Public Safety devil Hunters work full
time for the Japanese government and
they pretty much have to fight whoever
their boss tells them to fight this
means that a public safety agent is much
more likely to die facing off against
the strongest Devils but in exchange
they get a good benefits package and
paid days off work now back at HQ makima
spells out most of this to denji and he
begins to think that working in public
safety will be a good thing for his
master plan in his mind the more time
they spend together at work the better
odds he has of getting with makama
romantically and you know as a horny
teenager this is the most important
thing in the world to him however as he
gets his uniform makima unexpectedly
pairs him up with akihayakawa who is one
of the male devil Hunters also based in
Tokyo unlike denji Aki is a serious type
who has an intense hatred for all Devils
as his entire family was killed by a
devil when he was younger for that
reason he has strong personal
motivations for wanting to do this job
and later in the episode he mentions how
he loves to kill them in the most
painful way he can by contrast Genji is
someone who's been friends with the
Devil level he was willing to spare a
devil's life in the manga he can
transform into a devil and on top of
that his main career goal is to get with
makima from Aki's perspective someone is
unserious as this has no place in public
safety and it's why on their first
Patrol together he takes him into a dark
alley where he beats him up this beat
down was meant to be a warning for denji
to quit because to him anyone who does
this job for frivolous reasons ends up
dead every single time over the past
three years that he's been a devil
Hunter all of his teammates that got
into this career for money ended up
being killed and the only ones left
standing with those like him who had
strong convictions when it comes to
denji he obviously doesn't have any of
that and so although Aki is disgusted by
him he's also kind of trying to help him
in his own way because you know if denji
quits then at least he won't be murdered
by a devil following that he lights
another cigarette as he walks away but
before he can leave denji attacks his
balls with full force from behind one
thing we need to understand about denji
is that he has absolutely no code of
honor or anything like that so he has no
problem aiming for hack he's not the
entire fight as he continues to kick he
makes it clear that although his reasons
for being a devil Hunter might be
shallow it's still this job that allows
him to live his dream life so far on his
first day he's been able to have a
proper breakfast flirt with a girl and
get some brand new clothes which already
makes this a million times better than
working for the Yakuza because of that
he's not willing to give up his new life
so easily and NG keeps kicking akkie in
the balls until he gradually passes out
one interesting thing that was heavily
implied from their exchange is that Aki
also has a crush on mackuma as well so
his motivation to beat dengiarp is
partly fueled by jealousy especially
after she flirted with Dengue right in
front of him later on in the episode he
also gets loudly offended when he hears
that she gave denji a hug so yeah the
jealousy thing is definitely an element
in what's going on here some time later
back at HQ even though these two clearly
don't get along makima carries on with
her plan of putting denji into Aki's
unit within Public Safety there are
multiple units that each serve different
purposes and the team denji is joining
his special division 4 which is an exp
environmental Squad filled with the
weirdest people they have this place is
the best fit for Dengue mainly due to
his unusual talents and his weird
personality and so makima was always
going to put him there regardless of
whether Aki likes him or not in this
meeting makama then goes on to
explicitly confirm what we already knew
which is that if denji ever quits Public
Safety or disobeys his orders then he'll
be killed by them as if he was a devil
what this means is that for the rest of
his life he'll be working for them and
is presumably never allowed to retire
and you can tell from Aki's expression
that even he was surprised by this after
the meeting we then get confirmation
that these two will be living together
from this point forward and like makima
said if denji tries to run then Aki has
permission to kill him in that sense
chainsaw man is now totally the prisoner
of the Japanese government and as he
walks down the street he begins to
question machama's morality on the one
hand she has been kind to him and
treated him with more respect than the
Yakuza did but on the other side she's
also proven that she's willing to
sacrifice him if he doesn't do what she
says this confusion causes him to ask
Aki whether he thinks she's a bad person
but but considering that Aki also has a
crush on her I don't see a scenario
where he doesn't say that she's a good
person because denji has a simple mind
he takes this statement at face value
and chooses to think about the time she
was nice to him while disregarding all
the blatant threats she made to his life
now the next morning at Aki's house he
begins to fully live out his dreams but
in the process he triggers his new
roommate in a handful of different ways
for a start denji raised the kitchen to
create his ultimate toast which is
basically toast top with marmalade honey
butter cinnamon and three different
types of jam remember just a couple days
earlier he thought that putting jam on
his bread is something he'd never be
able to afford to do so to have all
these toppings is like a once in a
lifetime experience by itself that
probably doesn't get on Aki's nerves but
what annoys him is that denji kind of
just leaves the leftover mess all over
the living room table and he's super
loud when using the bath not to mention
that he also fell asleep while using the
toilet and then didn't replace the
missing toilet paper considering that
this is the first day of living together
you can tell that Aki doesn't feel
comfortable with the situation going on
hence why later in the episode he tries
to set denji up before we get to that
though the two of them are called out by
the police to deal with the fiend in my
last episode review I explained what a
fiend is but in case you haven't seen
that a fiend is a type of devil that
possesses the dead corpse of a human in
nearly all cases ifeen will have the
devil's personality and distinct
features on their head that lets
everyone know what they are this is
completely different to denji who still
retains his own personality and doesn't
have any weird features on his face
enabling him to mostly appear like a
normal human as he and Aki then arrive
at the house where the fiend is hiding
we see that an unknown devil has
possessed the body of a random
middle-aged man in the background
there's a cage for the bird that it's
currently eating and on the floor there
are tons of explicit magazines that
denji instantly notices not wanting to
get them dirty with blood he decides to
cleanly chop off this devil's head with
an ax rather than using his messy
chainsaws but when Aki questions that
decision Genji decides not to tell him
the truth maybe he thinks that Aki would
try to take the magazines for himself or
something but whatever the reason denji
pretends like he only killed the devil
this way to give it a painless death
this triggers Aki again because like we
established she hates Devils more than
anything and so for him to see a devil
Hunter sympathizing with Devils it makes
him even more suspicious of dengue than
he already was in reality though
chainsaw man didn't carry him the
slightest about the devil he killed but
I guess this cover story was needed to
hide his true horny motivations
following this denji has a moment of
self-reflection where he remembers his
contract with Vegeta and I guess the
issue here if you can call it that is
that he's already fulfilled his contract
within just a couple days what Vegeta
wanted was for denji to show him his
dreams which is something he's already
doing by you know eating good food
getting to watch himself getting to hang
around makima and just doing normal
things outside of work despite achieving
this perfect life he still feels like
there might be something missing which
plays into what he said in episode 1
when he realized that people will always
dream about having a better life no
matter how good their current life might
be this train of thought leads him to
wonder what his next true goal might be
and after thinking about makima he comes
to the conclusion that his real serious
goal in life is to touch her Booth
honestly I think I might have had a
similar dream to this at one point so
I'm not gonna act like it's that strange
especially considering that a hug is the
most he's ever gotten because of dendy's
previous financial situation he'd
completely given up on the idea of a
girl allowing him to touch her melons
but now that he has a good job the odds
are in his favor if he takes it
seriously this is where power comes in
as later in the episode she becomes his
new buddy at work thanks to ackee's
personal recommendation Genji and power
are paired up to patrol the neighborhood
for devils and what makes her special is
that she's not actually a Human Instead
power is a highly intelligent fiend
who's possessed the dead body of a
teenage girl but after zooming in on her
chest none of that matters to denji as
he views this as his best chance to
fulfill his brand new Dream On a related
No it should be said that no ordinary
theme would choose to become a devil
Hunter but due to Maxima's threats
Powers kind of been forced into this
lifestyle in that sense her and engine
in the same situation and that they're
both experiments who mcamer is testing
to see if they can do the job but if
they don't live up to her expectations
then yeah she's probably gonna kill them
in any case dengy and his new buddy then
start patrolling the rooftops for devils
and straight away it becomes clear just
how unpredictable power is although it's
true that she's smarter than the average
fiend she's still primarily motivated by
her basic double instincts which are to
kill things and to eat things that's why
she erratically runs around looking for
something to kill whether it be a devil
or a human I'm guessing and from this
Behavior denji realizes pretty early on
that she's a bit crazy but he's willing
to tolerate that craziness if it means
he gets to touch the melons as they
continue to walk they then come across
this cat just chilling on the roof and
although denji walked straight past it
power intensely stares at it and even if
she keeps walking her head is still
facing backwards this Fascination is
foreshadowing that cats are the only
animal she gets along with and this will
likely be explored further in the
episode next week for now though the two
of them keep searching the area for
Devils but they eventually take a break
after they can't find his single one
given that tracking down and capturing
Devils is pretty much their whole job
both their lives are at risk if they
can't get the results that Malcolm is
looking for in this scene power reveals
that the devils are likely avoiding them
because of her because back in the day
she used to be a powerful Devil with the
manga confirming that she was the blood
devil as you'd expect the blood devil
represents Humanity's fear of blood and
there are a decent amount of people out
there who do have this particular fear
it's not uncommon for people to faint
when they see blood or avoid situations
that would cause blood to be exposed and
all of that fear contributes to the
blood Devil's strength according to her
this strength is enough to scare the
weaker Devils away and while she could
be lying there is a reason why I think
she's at least partly telling the truth
remember denji and power will only
paired together because Aki suggested it
and if Powell's presence causes Devils
to run away then it means denji is less
likely to get results in that way Aki
has potentially set him up to fail which
is good news for him if it means that
denji stops being his roommate however
on the other hand I did mention in my
last video that Devils loses significant
amount of strength when they become
fiends so in theory power might not be
as strong as she thinks she is it's
equally possible that the reason they
haven't found any Devils is because
they're both just inexperienced and
maybe instead of setting denji up Aki
paired him with power so that he
wouldn't be the one looking after him
with that said episode 2 comes to an end
with power suddenly detecting the scent
of blood nearby and she quickly rushes
off leaving denji behind as he tries to
keep up she does some pretty impressive
parkour over the rooftops before
casually jumping off a building and in
this moment she activates her true power
one of her many abilities as the blood
devil is that she can manipulate her own
blood to create weapons and in this case
she transforms the blood coming out of
her wrist into a giant Mallet this
Mallet was made to crush the sea
cucumber devil down below but as we can
see there was already a civilian devil
Hunter dealing with the situation one of
the rules in Japan is that if a civilian
devil Hunter is involved with the devil
then it's illegal for Public Safety
double Hunters to just interfere and
kill it the reason for this rule is to
presumably protect the earnings of
Civilian Hunters who get paid based on
the Devils they capture and kill but in
this scene power just completely ignores
it as she splashes the sea cucumber in a
moment that was both colorful and
brilliantly animated now before we dive
into my personal rating for the episode
one thing I didn't find time to mention
was the painting in makima's office
which was visible as Aki pulled denji
across the floor this artwork seems to
be a similar style to the painting we
see in chapter 81 called the fall of
Lucifer which depicted Satan falling
from Heaven although the two paintings
aren't the same they definitely have the
same biblical tone so if you have any
idea where this new painting is from
then let me know in the comments Down
Below in terms of my thoughts on the
episode it did a lot of things that I
liked including amazing shots like the
one of makima's eye power destroying the
sea cucumber and the camera work on
Powers chess so I say that visually it
is more pleasing than episode 1. the one
thing I didn't like was that they
removed the muscle devil and don't get
me wrong I'm not pretending that this
was a big deal but I was kind of
surprised that they took it out
completely my guess is that they must
have like a specific point where they
won the the season to end and to reach
that point in the amount of episodes
they have I guess this was just a
necessary thing that had to be caught
however the reason I was surprised they
took it out is because last week during
episode one I mean that was the perfect
adaptation of the first chapter and so
to see such a huge chunk of episode two
you know being missing that was a big
shock overall though I'd still give this
episode a 9.5 out of 10. and if you want
these chainsaw man breakdowns to
continue then don't forget to hit that
sub button and drop a like if you're
feeling generous until the next one
peace out